so what is a 401k
a 401k is a retirement account you can
access only through your employer the
name comes from a section in the tax
code that first allowed these plans back
in the late 70s since then fall in one
case of groaning popularity with workers
and employers practically overshadowing
expensive pension plans with a 401k you
control higher money's invested a 401k
is a great place to save money for
retirement for a couple of reasons first
many employers match the money you put
into your 401k
up to a certain percentage of your
annual income so if you put 3 percent of
your salary into your 401k and your
employer offers a three percent dollar
for dollar match that instantly doubles
your contribution second the money in
your 401k grows tax-deferred which means
you don't pay taxes on it until you
withdraw it after you retired 401ks grow
in two ways one the money you put into
the fund piles up over the years which
is awesome and two compound growth
compound growth happens when the value
of the investments in your fallen k grow
and you reinvest that growth rather than
cash it out just think of it as profit
and when you're consistent about putting
money into your 401k and you let those
funds grow over your career you can
potentially live off that growth when
you retire which is also pretty sweet
you still need to live your life so
invest slow and steady and let the power
of compound interest work for you by
investing as soon as you can at Ramsey
solutions we believe you should start
investing once you're completely out of
debt and have an emergency fund in place
then you're really ready to invest my
friend Chris Hogan who's a retirement
expert puts it this way
investing is like a rollercoaster you
only get hurt if you jump off early we
want to find out how much money you're
gonna need for retirement check out the
our IQ tool at Chris Hogan 360 com
oh and last thing 401ks come with one
very important rule that money is for
retirement only you heard me only
basically this means you'll get
penalized in tax for taking any money
out of your 401k before fifty nine and a
half years old yes in this case the half
matters so leave it alone and now you
know
for more helpful videos like this one
make sure you subscribe to the channel
so you don't miss a thing